اذا مشاهدينا باقصى وسائل الترهيب كالقتل
والاعدام يواجه النظام الايراني شعبه
واحتجاجاته المستمره منذ شهور على خلفيه
مقتل الشابه الكرديه مهسه امين على يد ما
تسمى بشرطه الاخلاق انذاك نظام الدين حوت
وكذلك منصور حوت وهما متظاهران ايرانيان
من البلوش اعتقلتهما قواته الحرس الثوري
الايراني في الثلاثين من سبتمبر الماضي
بعد احتجاجات شعبيه واسعه على خلفيه قيام
احد قاده الشرطه في مدينه شهبهار باغتصاب
فتاه بلوشيه نقلت منظمات حالوا عن مصدر
مطلع تعرض منصور ونظام الدين حوت للتعذيب
الشديد اثناء اعتقالهما وتحت التعذيب اجبر
على الاعتراف واجبرا كذلك على التوقيع تحت
الضغط والتهديد من قبل المحققين الامنيين
في الاشهر الخمسه مرت منذ بدايه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه للمواطنين الايرانيين تم الكشف
عن حالات عديده من التعذيب والاعترافات
القصريه والتي لها تاريخ طويل في ايران
تقول حالوش كذلك انه تم اعتقال العديد من
المواطنين البلوش في زاهدان امس الاول وان
قوات الاستخبارات الحرس الثوريه الايراني
نقلتهم الى مكان مجهول وهذا ايضا بجانب
الاعتقال والاعدام هناك كذلك القتل ففي
الاشهر الخمسه الماضيه قتل مئات
المتظاهرين على ايدي قوات الامن والشرطه
واعتقل عشرات الالاف وذكرت منظمه حقوق
الانسان هانجا والكرديه اليوم الاحد ان
شابا يدعى مختار فتحي قتل بنيران مباشره
من القوات الامنيه في مدينه سقز التابعه
لمحافظه كردستان غرب ايران هذا الشاب اذا
هو من سكان مدينه سقس وهي مسقط راس ماسه
اميني التي فجر مقتلها الاحتجاجات الحاليه
[موسيقى]